[Music]
deras Lari after we went into the line
on the western side of the island the
regiment stayed and continuously from
the tenth or eleventh day until the 35th
day the casualties were very high the
land looked like a section of the moon
it is impossible to describe the
ruggedness of the cliffs and land on the
northern half of the island from about
the middle of the island to the northern
end on the west side the cliffs ran
diagonally across the front of our lines
there was a cliff about every 40 or 50
yards the averaged about a hundred feet
in height and were made of hard
sulfurous clay a dirty yellow in color
there was no vegetation on them and the
bombs artillery shells and naval gunfire
shells had knocked off large chunks of
this rocky clay in each side of one of
these cliffs were in innumerable caves
some of these cliffs had as many as 40
caves on each side some of these caves
went down 40 or 50 feet in the Japs had
carved out large rooms down there some
of them were 40 or 50 feet square
most of the caves were connected with
several others by tunnels all of these
caves had Japs in them it was impossible
to get them out with artillery or mortar
fire the only way our men could advance
was for fire teams to fire continuously
into the mouths of the next cave while
flamethrower men worked their way
through to burn them out this was
followed by demolitions teams who made
their way to the cave with TNT charges
and blew up the cave mouths sealing off
the Japs in them most of the time the
caves was situated so the Japs could
cover each other in that case our men
had to work on several caves at the same
time then the Japs would run through the
tunnels and out into the caves on the
other side of the cliffs when our men
reached the high ground of the cliff
ridge they had to fire on caves on the
opposite cliffs while the men worked
their way down the reverse slope of the
cliff they were on to get to the Japs
below them there was no other way to
accomplish this I did not go up to the
front lines any more than I had to
it was frightful there every few days I
went up with Colonel Williams but not
any more than I had to bullets came from
every direction up there through
crevices in the rocks and the Japs were
constantly lobbing mortar shells marina
was behind the next line of cliffs he
could go up into the battalion supply
distributing points every day they were
200 to 400 yards back once in a while I
would go up to the company command posts
with a battalion supply personnel these
sea peas were from 30 yards to 100 yards
behind the front lines every time I went
up there I got sick at the stomach will
write more next letter
love red
[Music]
you
[Music]